spiderman no way home did an incredible
job in the box office so it makes sense
that they would want to give the fans
what they want
more of it we're breaking down every
additional moment and scene that was
included in the more fun stuff cut
number one
before the movie even kicks off we get
introduced to the three peters they open
it up with a thank you to the fans for
turning it into something much more than
just another spider-man film toby
maguire said it was a beautiful
experience which then follows up with
him and tom holland telling andrew
garfield that they love him which is a
callback to the improvised line andrew
made in the film where he tells the
other two spider-men that he loves them
not only do we get three spider-men in
one film we get to see them bring an
iconic meme to life
number two
we get a bit more of an expansion on the
interrogation scene it's brief but now
we've got some added questions about the
washington monument from spider-man
homecoming we also see the file that
agent cleary slams down on the desk it's
a photo of peter in his black suit from
spider-man far from home
cleary wasn't shy about the fact that he
wanted to know everything peter knows
about the night monkey
number three peter's high school
experience took a major turn in the
original showing after begrudgingly
getting past security and having to
leave mj at the door
he's shown walking through midtown high
as everyone awkwardly takes photos and
videos of him in a new addition to this
midtown high experience his gym teacher
coach wilson who has been clear about
his preference to mysterio from the very
beginning starts a chant of climate
climate
to which peter reluctantly shows off his
spidey skills for the entire gym class
it's not easy being peter parker and
spider-man at the same time
number four
sign us up for whatever movie is gonna
happen here in the extended cut of the
film we get a bit more playful banter
between the guys in the original cut
andrew says he's always wanted brothers
and then went on to ask toby about his
webs since he's the only spider-man that
organically makes them if you know how
tobe maguire's spider-man actually makes
his webs definitely let us know in the
comments in the more fun stuff version
garfield furthers his statement about
wanting brothers with suggesting they
all hang out
but they decide to focus on the battle
at hand instead
we're not too sure they can actually
call each other through the multiverse
but we are willing to overlook that to
get more of this spider-man gold
number five
one of the most emotional moments in the
film
in the original cut peter tells mj she's
going to forget who he is because of
doctor strange's spell though she's
resistant she knows there's nothing she
can do so she tells him that she loves
him when he tries to say it back she
tells him to wait until he sees her
again to say it in the extended she asks
him if they can both be strangers
together basically she's asking if they
can both be wiped from the world's
memory but still remember each other
unfortunately for her and us that's not
how it ends up going down this was such
a beautiful line that though we're sad
it didn't make it into the theatrical
version we're glad to get to see it here
in the second
number six a superhero and his aunt step
into an elevator with four super
villains yeah that's pretty much what
happens here
in this deleted scene we get to see how
everyone ended up in harry's apartment
before they ended up destroying it
anyway in the original cut it just
starts out with everyone caught on the
doorbell cam stepping inside the
apartment which leads us to another
important moment in the film
number 7.
happy lucked out with getting matt
murdock as his lawyer in the original
cut of the film there's a short scene
where matt tells peter the charges
against him won't stick but
unfortunately for happy he will need a
strong defense in the more fun stuff
version we saw earlier that the scene
opens up with a team of villains cramped
inside happy's elevator with peter and
may right after it follows with agent
cleary and a team of dodc agents further
interrogating happy while matt murdock
defends him and says he is a law-abiding
citizen
at that exact moment the doorbell cam
footage of all the villains entering his
apartment pops up on his phone though it
is impressive how matt can tell we are
sure if someone was sweating as much as
happy probably was it wouldn't be too
difficult
number eight we get some additional
comedy from betty brant's burning
questions
we see an interview with coach wilson mr
harrington mr dell flash ned and peter
coach wilson goes on about conspiracy
theories
one in particular being that justin
timberlake was never in nsync mr
harrington talks about his ex-wife going
on reddit deep dives and mr dell talks
about how he'd be much sexier if he were
the one bitten by the spider this
sequence runs on for about three to four
minutes and while it's fun we can
understand why it didn't make the og cut
number nine not only do we get to see
the statue of liberty before she
crumbles to pieces but betty also gives
us a segment where the students of
midtown high create alternate models for
her the designs include different
avengers like black widow hawkeye hulk
and thor
number 10.
typical flash he gets another random
scene that didn't make it to the
theatrical version
flash gets to bask in his glory as
students fall over him to get him to
sign their copy of flashpoint it doesn't
really add much to the film but it's
nice to see an extra moment of
ridiculous comedy
number eleven
they've switched out eddie for betty in
the original post-credits scene eddie
unlike all the other villains doesn't go
looking for peter parker he's at a bar
learning all about mcu history when he
finally decides to talk to peter it's
too late and he gets sent back to his
own universe
so now instead of listening to eddie
argue with his inner venom we get betty
brant's final news segment where she's
sharing pictures of the kids adventures
throughout school this includes footage
from the homecoming dance and the class
trip to europe
but peter's face isn't in any of the
footage thus showing that he's
essentially erased from history dr
strange's spell worked
did this get anyone else right in the
fields
number 12.
the burglar also known as tom holland's
brother carrie holland shortly before
peter gets harassed on the street by
pedestrians he webs up the robber
instead of being grateful for his
heroics one of the women the one who
says he's just a kid and shouldn't be
doing this anymore accuses him of being
in cahoots with the robber to which
peter responds with i don't know this
guy the irony is not lost on us
the robber even plays into it and tells
everyone that he and spider-man do know
each other and are in cahoots it
essentially creating more of a mess
the scene ends with a mysterio fan
running up and throwing green paint on
him causing him to turn his spider-man
suit inside out all we see in the
original are the pedestrians arguing
over what teenagers should be allowed to
do
we only see the green paint getting
thrown on him in a clip from the daily
bugle after the fact
and let's be honest who doesn't love a
good paint toss moment something you
might have missed about this scene was
mr delmar's deli
one of peter's favorite spots that was
destroyed in spider-man homecoming
well it's now called del mar's three
during a fight at the bank where a group
of criminals are trying to rob the atms
the bank gets blown up and the delhi
which is across the street ends up
burning down because of it you
definitely gotta have good insurance if
you own an mcu business
did you notice the new remodel of del
mar's deli during your first watch
through
these extended and added scenes do
contribute a lot more fun stuff to the
movie as well as helping us gain some
insight and deeper meaning to
spider-man's universe what was your
favorite scene that made it to the more
fun stuff version
you